there was a great disservice that was
done to capitalism um over the course of
the 80s 90s and 2000s um and that
disservice was perpetuated by leaders
like Jack
Welch um and basically what they did is
they made business in America more about
value to a shareholder an external
constituent over a customer or an
employee and remember good oldfashioned
Adam Smith capitalism the kind of
capitalism that made America great the
kind of capitalism that Thomas Jefferson
studied Thomas Jefferson owned all the
volumes of Wealth of
Nations um that form of capitalism
believed in competition as a means of
producing a higher quality product we
now live in a world where that's not
really
true um that when a company for example
announces Mass layoffs to meet some
arbitrary Financial
projection um we see a stock price goes
up go up this is a big problem um and
many of the inherent deals that were
made between a company and this employer
or a company and the customer used to be
you know that we will work tirelessly in
our competitive Spirit to make a better
product from you and we will work
tirelessly to look after our people so
that our people give back years of
loyalty and unfortunately this Young
Generation has has grown up in a world
where Mass layoffs are so
normalized where they've watched their
parents or their friends parents be laid
off through no fault of their own it was
not a
meritocracy just because the company
missed like I said an AR arbitrary
projection it's profitable just not as
profitable as we expected so you get to
lose your job as a result so I can go
back and prove to somebody that I
balance the books even though I'm doing
long-term damage to the culture of the
company and that deal was broken that
deal was broken that I'm going to take
care of you and you're going to take
care of me and so it's very funny to me
that companies lament that this young
generation seems to offer no loyalty to
the
company um when they offer they have
offered none for
decades um and in the process of of
business becoming Much More shortterm
Much More transactional and the human
element um falling to the Wayside we've
also seen a decline in a very very very
specific skill set called human skills
right I I hate the term soft skills hard
term hard skills and soft skills hard
and soft are opposite that means they
work in opposition to each other right
hard skills the skills you need to do
your job and human skills the skills you
need to be a better human being and both
of those are important to be a great
entrepreneur and a and a and a great and
and a great business person and though
we teach hard skills and we teach how to
read a balance sheet and what a p&l is
and we teach all of these wonderful
things unfortunately we started to treat
people like something on a p&l and what
we have to do better is teaching human
skills human skills include things like
listening like uh empathy like how to
give and receive feedback like how to
have a difficult conversation these are
vital skills in a modern day that we
don't teach which means our Business
Leaders do not have those skills
and if you want to build culture if you
want to build trust you need these
skills if you want to manage difficult
times you need to have these
skills take for example what happened
after the murder of George Floyd and I
saw this pervasive the number of leaders
after the murder of George Floyd do
nothing not because they're bad people
it's because they were too afraid to
have a conversation about race with
their team fearing that they would say
the wrong thing and accident inflame a
situation or trigger somebody so they
chose
nothing and I don't fault them for it
what they're missing is a necessary
skill set how to have a difficult
conversation hey team we need to have a
difficult conversation um I'm afraid to
have this conversation I fear I'm gonna
say the wrong thing or accidentally
trigger somebody and I and I and I'm and
I need your help because I I'm going to
Fumble this but it's more important that
we have this conversation than not
simply because I'm afraid that's how you
start a difficult conversation that is a
teachable learnable practice practicable
practice skill set so one thing that I
would like to see more of in our
University system to prepare young
people as they enter the workforce
whether they choose an entrepreneurial
path or not is to be better equipped
with these skills because their
companies as of now are doing a poor job
of equipping them and and if they are
going to be the Future Leaders um I want
them to bring these skills to business
to repair the capitalism and repair the
Damage Done by folks like Jack w